Today is google's developer program Meiji Tanihara in Meiji
is
Today about fuses and locations and geofences
The maps api v1 will be introduced together with the stand
google maps android api v1 to is android
It is an api that can be used by embedding google map in the app
2d display was significantly improved from around v 1 by default
It supports 360-degree rotation by gesture and also switches between map aerial photographs and
It corresponds to the indoor map
The ps location is provided by Google Play service is
It is a function
The main feature is that api is very easy to use
Also, you can get location information anytime soon, yet the battery consumption of the app is minimized
An app that can hold back
From the direct use on the screen to the regular position in the background net background
It has become api corresponding to a wide range of applications to obtain information
The fence is an api for detecting intrusions into the circular area and the constitution.
api is simple, but it is powerful as it can delete multiple upper variables registered in Ishido.
Live implementation is now underground
According to the distance from the current location to the area and the moving speed
It is designed to reduce battery consumption by adjusting the frequency of location update
Before we look at the actual usage, we will look at what the setup should do
Both maps api and location client introduced this time
It is included in the play service Izu client library
If you are using Grades to build a projector
Just add a line to the build.
You can add a library
If you are using Eclipse sdk directory
Extract google google play service easlib project
Add to the project as a library project
You need api key to use maps api
You can get the api key from the console without the google developer.
Be careful because it is different from google play developer's console
Please give me
Please access the url you see
Create a new project with the Create Project button
Click api on the left tab in the created project and click api
Open the tab
Look for the item google maps android api v1 to
Turn on the right toggle button
Once you've done that, open the cree train Luz on the left tab this time and get public api
Press the Create New Key button under Access
Type of key to create choose android key
Keystore fingerprint and app package in the displayed text box
Enter a combination of names
Separate the fingerprint and package name with a semicolon as in the example shown
Since you can enter multiple combinations, for example, you can store key stores for both debugging and reasoning
Can register
Once it has been registered, it has a reputation for being a key for android application
Since you can do that, you will need a string later that says api key
Add metadata to app package to use maps api v 2
need to do it
Immediately below the manifest element of android manifest xml
Add metadata elements as you see
Please put the api key acquired earlier in the api key part
To use the maps api and the location client
You need permission to view as well as before
Add it directly under the elements of the manifest of android manifest xml
Please give me
The first four are the required permissions to use map map The remaining two are
It's for the location client Now you're ready
First, let's take a quick look at how to use maps api
Unlike in v 1 maps api v 2 maps are provided as fragments
Will be
In the example you see, support map fragment in the sound creation method of activity
A class called map fragment in addition to the support map fragment being generated
There is also api level 12
I will only meet at the above
Support instance of google map class for map fragment class
You can get it with the get map method
However, it is necessary to be careful because it will be painted until the loading is complete but will come back
Various processing will be done through this google map class
For example, of map
When setting the display position, move camera method of google map class
Use
If you use the set my location na verdo method
can be displayed on map
Now let's use a location client class that provides field location
Let's see
Instantiating the calculation client is just new
In the example you see, the fragment's sound register creation method is used to call it the first one
The second argument of the argument is a connection callback
The third is a connection field listener There is not on the screen, but two inter
You need to implement each face method
If you can create an instance call the connect method
And compute client ready to use
To start continuous acquisition of location information
Use one method in request location up Connection call here
Calling from back interface book connected method
Take an instance of Location Dragon Quest as the first argument
Always say in the set priority method
Ise to specify the update interval in the sendral set interval method
I will specify
In this example, the highest priority as priority is designated as 8 lives.
But I also want to shine with the priority balance and power itilow hack low
power
Because there is power of priority, let's use properly depending on the application
The second argument is the location rate
It is a location of the sound location change of the interface like the service
Override the method
This method is called whenever the location information is updated
Call the move location up date method when the update is no longer needed
I will stop the capital high
Here we are calling from the fragment's sound pose method
Finally, let's see how to use dione face
Temporarily create an instantiation of the fence through the builder class
Specify unique string id with set request id
The red transition type specifies when to call back
As shown in this example, when entering the area when entering the transition or
If it is a transition exit, it is when it leaves the area
Specify deadline for cows in zx piration duration
In this example, this geofence is set to be effective all the time
Then specify the center point and radius of the Philia in the set circular region
In order to actually set the upper variable, the hatto of the location client class
Call the fence is method
An array of geofences as the first argument
The second argument is the pending intent The third argument is the on at the teacher orphen
Specify the seeds result seeds
The pending intent specified here will be later when a geofence event occurs
Used
It is a template of the intent In this example the reception of the event is
Because we decided to do with the intent service,
I refine using the static method of Get service
Hmm
Let's take a look at the contents of the intent service that receives geofence events
Now override the handle intent method and tober ride
Processing the intent passed as an argument then the location client
You can use the static methods provided by the class
Should be error and get error code is available for error handling
If you use the ket geo-fence transition, the kana part of anyone gets in the area
I can do it
get List of faces where birds are feeling the ring geo fence for the current event
Returns a value obtained using a method like the one above
Perform processing for the face once
How was it? The functions of maps api v 2 and location client
If you combine
The potential of the app service is likely to expand greatly Thank you for watching